good morning John so it's a little
shocking to me and like a lot of other
people that a 14 year old kid in a NASA
shirt brought a clock that he built to
school to show his engineering teacher
and was arrested and taken to a juvenile
detention center then on the other hand
it's not shocking because hamed
Mohammed's name is Ahmed Mohamed and he
is Muslim and many people in America are
afraid of Muslims now I'm not going to
make a video here about how the vast
vast vast majority of Muslims just like
any other broad diverse group of people
are good people two reasons for that
first finding statistics on the internet
that make this very clear is pretty easy
second making a video defending Muslims
would ignore the actual problem which is
the bias and the fear-mongering that
creates suspicion and hatred and those
things are our problems and our problems
we can deal with so much more easily
than trying to deal with other people's
problems especially when those problems
are imagined now of course it's not
super comfortable to recognize your own
problems and it doesn't make you feel
all good which is why this video is not
gonna go super viral but since it is the
actual problem and also one that we can
deal with conceivably since we are the
ones with the problem that's what I want
to make the video about so why do so
many Americans including I'll be honest
sometimes myself fall into this fear
trap first because it's just impossible
to know everything about everyone and
though Muslims have been in America
since America existed they are a
significant minority less than 1% so
most Americans simply don't know much
about Muslims or the Islamic faith but
we do hear about Muslims fairly
regularly on the news and we hear about
the scariest Muslims in the world so if
you're expected to have an idea of what
Muslim people are alike and this is the
only input you're giving you're gonna
have a really messed-up idea it's an
easy mistake for a brain to make but it
is a huge mistake because we know
nothing an example what percentage of
Muslims would you say live in the Middle
East 80% 85% that's what I would have
said before starting to research this
video about 20 percent 60 percent of
Muslims live in Asia the single country
with the largest Muslim population
Indonesia if we are ignorant of such a
basic fact
how could we consider ourselves
qualified to make sweeping
generalizations about a broad and
diverse group of people once these
negative ideas are set up in our brain
they can be easily reinforced in people
who
are motivated by fear and outrage those
people watch other people on TV who
professionally cultivate outrage and
fear because it's good for ratings and
that fear then prevents conversations
and causes the majority to isolate
Muslims from their broader communities
by doing things like for example
arresting a kid for bringing a clock to
class so the fear builds on itself until
what was once ignorant and became fear
eventually becomes hatred and once you
hate someone they know it last ones in
America are certainly not ignorant of
the hatred and the discrimination but
Muslims and other countries aren't
ignorant of the more extreme American
views either dr. moonda bet that in the
same way that we hear mostly just about
scary Muslims on American news in other
countries they hear mostly about the
scariest versions of Americans if people
in other countries are gonna put us in a
little box which they are bound to do
because no one can know everything about
everyone what little box do we want to
get put into do we want to be in the
hates Muslims box or do we want to be in
the values religious freedom and
provides opportunities for people who
seek it Fox I think we should fight that
fear I think we can fight that fear and
the only way to do it the only place to
do it is up here it's right in here John
I'll see you on Tuesday